wir hören an diesem morgen von weiterer
eskalation auf vielen ebenen zwischen
israelis und palästinensern
gegenreaktion folgt auf reaktion folgt
auf aktion fragen wir alexander graf
lambsdorff vorsitzender der
deutsch-israelischen
parlamentariergruppe im deutschen
bundestag was erleben wir gerade im
nahen osten aus ihrer sicht ich glaube
wir erleben gerade das zusammentreffen
vieler verschiedener trends die sich zu
einer eskalation jetzt hoch geschaukelt
haben die geradezu dramatische ausmaße
angenommen hat und in der die terror
organisationen hamas und islamischer
jihad israel mit einem flächendeckenden
raketenangriff überzogen haben
ohne jede unterschiede zwischen
zivilbevölkerung militärischen zielen
also mit anderen worten der der reine
terrorismus wenn man mal auf die
faktoren schaut wir haben das ende des
ramadan
wir hatten den jerusalem tag den
radikale siedler gerne benutzen um die
araber zu provozieren
wir haben eine gescheiterte
regierungsbildung in israel eine
weiterlaufende und wir haben
abgesagte wahlen in den
palästinensergebieten mit anderen worten
es kommt alles gleichzeitig zusammen die
lage ist leider wirklich schlimm ist das
also herr graf lambsdorff die schuld der
radikalen palästinenser organisationen
hamas und es ist immer schwer im nahen
osten einfach eine schuld zuzuschreiben
nur eines ist klar alle konflikte über
die wir hier reden also einschließlich
beispielsweise dessen was die
korrespondenten gerade berichtet haben
aus ost jerusalem
keiner von denen ist auch nur annähernd
eine rechtfertigung für einen massiven
raketen- angriffe auf die
zivilbevölkerung insofern das was hier
jetzt gerade passiert diese großen
flächen deckenden angriffe die sind
eindeutig auf das konto der hamas und
des islamischen jihad zu buchen und
damit tragen sie an der aktuellen
situation die schuld ja welche
verantwortung hat aus ihrer sicht israel
hat benjamin netanyahu haben die
israelis
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass der
streit sich ursprünglich entzündete an
einigen häusern in ost jerusalem das
sind aber häuser die von jüdischen
familien bewohnt waren bevor jordanien
sie besetzt hat die haben vor gericht
jetzt recht bekommen dass sie diese
häuser zurück bekommen sollen
da ist nicht immer alles ganz geschickt
gemacht worden nur sie merken schon an
der schilderung die ich ihnen hier
gerade gebe es geht um einige häuser in
einem stadtviertel von jerusalem
das ist emotional aufgeladen richtig
aber es ist keine rechtfertigung für
massenhaften terror mit raketen gegen
die zivilbevölkerung deswegen netanjahu
trägt hier keine schuld in dem sinne
sondern es ist eine verfahrene situation
über 1948 1967 über die verschiedenen
intifada als über den gaza-krieg 2014
ich will nur hoffen dass aus der
aktuellen aktuellen situation nicht ein
neuer gaza krieg wird wie 2014 es wäre
schrecklich viele todesopfer also das
geht dann in die tausende das ist
wirklich etwas was nicht passieren darf
und wo wir als bundesrepublik als
europäische union als westen insgesamt
auch alles tun sollten um das zu
verhindern was sagen sie denen die sagen
benjamin netanyahu der ministerpräsident
von israel hat in den letzten monaten
und jahren auch keinerlei aufstand getan
um in irgendeiner weise auf die
palästinenser zuzugehen beziehungsweise
gemeinsam eine lösung für den
jahrelangen konflikt zu finden
ich bin auch durchaus kritisch was
manchen vorschlag aus der israelischen
politik angeht das schließt auch die
maßnahmen beziehungsweise das fehlen der
maßnahmen des premierministers 1
auf der anderen seite muss man ihm zu
rechnen dass er natürlich auf der
palästinensischen seite keine
gesprächspartner hat mahmoud abbas ist
seit 15 jahren der präsident auf der
westbank hat alle wahlen immer wieder
abgesagt hält sich an der macht fest ist
demokratisch nicht legitimiert der
gaza-streifen aus dem sich israel ja und
ich glaube das haben viele schon wieder
vergessen
zurückgezogen hat also im gazastreifen
gibt es keine israelische besatzung wird
von der radikal islamistischen hamas
dominiert und von dort aus kommen wir
jetzt auch die raketen also bei aller
kritik an vielleicht nicht genug
schwung oder nicht genug elan für eine
dauerhafte friedenslösung ist doch die
situation auf der palästinensischen
seite noch erheblich verfahren als auf
der israelischen und das hört man auch
immer wieder von palästinensern die an
einer friedlichen lösung interessiert
sind anders eben als die terroristen die
gerade diese angriffe starten
verstehe ich sie richtig herr graf
lambsdorff wenn die palästinenser
innerpalästinensische zu einer klaren
führung kamen die es zwar auf dem papier
gibt aber wie viele sagen nicht in der
realität dann wäre israel auch sofort
bereit über eine zwei-staaten- lösung
wieder zu diskutieren aus ihrer sicht
das ist in der israelische ein großer
streit aber die internationale
gemeinschaft steht fest auf dem boden
der abkommen von oslo
da ist die zwei staaten lösung als das
ziel ausgegeben und genau das ist dann
auch das was wir unterstützen würden
ob es in der israelisch dazu kommt dass
man sich auf eine solche lösung einig
wir wissen dass es einige parteien gibt
die das nicht wollen ist eine andere
frage aber ich glaube dass die
voraussetzungen dafür mit den
palästinensern eine langfristige lösung
zu haben in der die palästinenser in
würde in einem eigenen staat leben
können und israel in sicherheit und
frieden in wirklich allen anerkannten
und akzeptierten grenzen
das setzt voraus dass es auf der
palästinensischen seite erstens eine
demokratisch legitimierte führung und
zweitens auch den wirklichen willen gibt
eine lösung zu erreichen
es ist ja nicht so dass nur in israel
diskutiert wird ob man von der
eskalation profitiert teilweise bei den
radikalen kräften sondern auf der
palästinensischen seite ist das ja viel
viel ausgeprägter
die hamas versucht ja gerade die
arabische welt wieder auf ihre seite zu
kriegen insbesondere wegen der
ereignisse um die al aksa moschee gibt
es denn diese diesen willen auf seiten
der palästinenser und auf seiten der
israelis aus ihrer sicht tatsächlich
diese zwei staaten lösung wie sie im
abkommen von oslo der angesprochene
haben von 92 93 verabredet wurden ja
maßgebliche kräfte in der israel wollen
die zwei staaten lösung nach wie vor
andere ergreifen maßnahmen die diese
zwei staaten lösung erschweren wir haben
als bundesrepublik deutschland wir haben
als freie demokraten als europäische
union auch manche dieser maßnahmen
kritisiert wie beispielsweise bestimmte
bauen
jungen für siedlungen östlich von
jerusalem die die zwei staaten lösung
erschweren
also es ist ein politischer streit auf
palästinensischer seite glaube ich wäre
man an einer zwei staaten lösung
interessiert nur da stellt sich die
frage ob die palästinensische seite
tatsächlich dann zufrieden wäre oder ob
sie nicht eine agenda verfolgen würde
die weiter den druck auf israel erhöhen
würde und die legitimität israels
insgesamt als staat infrage stellen
würde denn auch das ist von
palästinensischer seite zu hören und das
ist für uns absolut inakzeptabel
der un sicherheitsrat kommt heute zu
einer dringlichkeitssitzung wieder mal
zusammen am montag hat man sich da nicht
groß einigen können was kann das heute
bringen beziehungsweise der graf
lambsdorff zum abschluss wo kann dieser
konflikt noch hin laufen wo der konflikt
jetzt hin laufen kann ist offen ist es
gut dass im sicherheitsrat darüber
gesprochen wird auch wenn es schwierig
ist in dem gremium zur zeit zu
entscheidungen zu kommen die russische
seite ist ja da immer sehr schnell mit
einem veto zur hand aber der konflikt
kann im moment zu einer großen
auseinandersetzung gar zu einem krieg
führen ich habe eben gesagt niemand kann
sich wünschen dass wir noch einmal 2014
erleben er kann aber auch sich wieder
entspannen er kann auch wieder das hoffe
ich auch sehr dazu führen dass wir zu
normalen gesprächen wieder zurückkehren
ich würde mir vor allem wünschen dass
die arabischen staaten an die sich
israel diplomatisch in den letzten
anderthalb jahren angenähert hat dass
die hier eine konstruktive rolle spielen
das wäre in meinen augen der richtige
weg zum beispiel indem man noch mal
redet über die arabische
friedensinitiative als einen baustein
eines dialogs und eine
friedensinitiative vorbereitet die auch
die beiden administration in washington
mit trägt denn eines ist klar ohne die
usa wird eine dauerhafte lösung nicht
geben können so sitzt wahrscheinlich aus
alexander graf lambsdorff fdp
außenpolitiker und vorsitzender der
deutsch-israelischen
parlamentariergruppe vielen vielen dank
der graf lambsdorff